technology giant Samsung is trying to
make a comeback in the global phone
business with two new smartphones a
South Korean company announced its
highly anticipated galaxy s 8 and s 8
plus devices yesterday now these are the
first models following the company's
debacle last year with the galaxy note 7
Samsung were called more than two and a
half million phones after some of the
batteries caught fire Dan Ackerman from
our partners had seen it tested the new
s8
and he joins us now with latest hot off
the presses let's just say it's a pretty
phone it's gorgeous and the first thing
you see is that it's almost all screen
that we're going to this kind of new new
design where you get rid of the bezels
around the side and the top and bottom
ones have been reduced to almost nothing
the home button the thing you find in
every phone is physically gone it's an
on screen button now so if you look at
an image you just get the entire image
over the entire screen like this and if
you want the home button back you can
tap on it what security options does it
have you know they've got a fingerprint
reader that is instead of the button
it's now on the back there's also iris
scanning which is a bit involved and a
more casual face unlock so you have
three forms of biometric security so if
I turn the phone off and on you see it's
locked right here but if I just look at
it now it's unlocked
just like the iris scan that's the face
game which is lit faster the iris scan
takes a little bit more time but you can
also just use a passcode which frankly
is probably the most occurred because
nobody can force you to unlock with a
passcode they can force you to use your
fingerprint or your face they can hold
your face right like a border crossing
or something so the big question is do
you think this has enough new features
so that people forget we've had a couple
years where phones have sort of been in
the dole and we've seen a lot of phones
that look and feel exactly the same this
is one of the first ones that takes a
step forward in terms of design in terms
of features where you have this all-over
screen and you'll start seeing this
going forward in other phones maybe that
you know new iPhone that's going to come
later this year they may copy some of
these features as well and they're
adding extra stuff like extra assistance
everyone's got their own personalized
voices system now they're all they have
one called Bixby and you can actually
get to it just by hitting this little
button on the side here and you get your
personalized car with all your stuff on
it so it's a little walkie-talkie button
instead of going hey Siri and what can
also make reso desktop - Kim yes there's
a dock you can buy and people have tried
this for years and it's never worked
before it's called the decks and you
plug the phone in
it's got a monitor and a keyboard
attached and then you can use this like
an Android powered desktop
the phones are finally powerful enough
to do this I like this kind of a
security play there where you have your
stuff on here maybe you give a
presentation and then you just take the
entire phone with you when you walk away
instead of putting your data on someone
else's computer or leaving it on a
computer that stays somewhere yeah and
Bixby's cute yeah he's cute how much is
it selling more you know these are gonna
be you know they're premium phones I'm
750 to 850 a little bit more maybe
depending on which of the two screen
sizes you get and how much memory you
get there's no battery fire because this
is a big deal for them don't you think
or do we have to say onward now that was
then this is now I mean that was a big
deal and they rip the band-aid off by
recalling that phone and they did a
whole big report in January detailing
what happened so hopefully this is
probably the safest phone you could buy
right now Dan Ackerman thank you so much